liked in a while on our good friend
carlos navarro from monsters in the
morning how is carlos god you know
he's putting together good content he's
putting together good content i just
it's nice to go back to carlos right can
we just breathe for a minute it feels
good right
relief and just kind of be
bask in the glory of the fact that we're
back in carlos navarro
realm like last night and i was doing
cooking with jack
and it just was like ah forgot how fun
it was to laugh
it's nice um carlos this
guy so uh monsters in the morning he
made this video
uh january 27th it has 119 views
and everyone should report him for using
the nba you cannot use
the nba trademark check this out
best new players of all time that's a
great audio michael jordan
shaq dr j great audio mixing
it's really good he's um he's really
good he's
uh he's a radio
guy yes uh he's on the biggest fm radio
show in central florida the monsters in
the morning
yes mike we're not like i mean we've
we've had some pro gigs but for the most
part we've remained
self-taught and fairly independent
correct in our many years doing this
yes uh you ever heard of uh
normalize yeah that's like the no the
first thing i learned how to do was
normalize
the first thing i learned one of the
first things you're taught see folks for
the few laymen at home
and some of you need to learn this and
i'm not naming names blues doll
but what i love bluestall but i've told
her before
you gotta normalize so you take the
whole finished project
at the end and then you run this thing
called normalize and what it does is it
makes
all the clips like that pulls the low
ones up and it brings the high ones down
and they all meet in the middle
right so that you're listening to one
piece yeah but
what he what he lacks in uh technology
he makes up for a comedy
okay okay so let's watch carlos now
um carlos okay
so he's having nba players he's the
greatest he's the greatest basketball
player of all time but what so what's
the get what so the bid is because he's
not
that's the [ __ ]
so why would lebron and these guys say
that i don't think they're really saying
that
um you can tell he's been playing
against some high level competition
[Music]
crafty
it's a guy that knows how to play but
see he's just
the game seems awfully slow for him like
he can just
you know just kind of manipulate the
game as it's going along
he's got all the savvy moves of older
guys
this is mental health
what's the joke here carlos i know
it's funny too mr bally song says oh
sweet vince to cola
i literally just referenced vince to
cola
in the last break and you happen to play
this dumb [ __ ] that has
the [ __ ] rocky 4 music oh yep
that's so but the bit is that he's not
good at basketball
so man wouldn't it be crazy if like
lebron said i was
the greatest basketball player
and then what is this that see here's
the problem this is that's mental
illness
carlos oh god do we have more carlos
stuff
do you have oh i want more carlos right
now sure i got this
i want to break this guy down because i
took ritalin today
i want to break this guy i got it i got
it because it like i start getting on my
little
fits or i want to examine people
he's he's carlos is opera
he's making content that operates
under the assumption that he's already
so famous
yes that it's already funny yeah it's
exciting
like like he's doing a jimmy fallon tear
a
bit
would be the best way to describe this
right correct is that not exactly frame
for frame
some terrible [ __ ] jimmy fallon yeah i
would say yes
except jimmy would have probably just
gotten them guys to say that
and made a bit and it wouldn't have been
any more funny
that it was jimmy fallon except it would
have gotten laughs because you're like
oh it's jimmy fallon he's familiar to me
um but that's what carlos does carlos
does jimmy fallon ask bits
where it's like man would it be wacky if
like i inserted myself into stuff
not really carlos you're a hacky one
market radio jock
you ain't know let me tell you something
i'm not a big jimmy fallon fan
that being said i've seen jimmy fallon
i've worked with jimmy fallon and you
sir i know jimmy fallon
uh don't forget carlos did a voice in
red dead redemption here's another video
it sounded a little something like this
we played this one before but i think
it's worth revisiting
no
hey hang on get away from me oh you're
weird
i would never date you i only think hot
ass big ass cat man
you want to dance baby you want to bump
and cry
no way yeah you want to go take a ride
you got to burn loose
you need white bigger muscles to date me
because i'm super hot and sexy
come on i'm going to call the police
i'll punch you in your ugly throat what
do you want to do
okay good i'm sorry i i am
i am amazed how good he is
i'm at a loss for words you're not a
mesa okay i was wrong i
i am i'm i'm i'm
full of dread is that
was that wait was that the point of that
carlos were you trying to make something
that would
that would fill me with dread how many
views does this stuff have oh my god
two 226 poor [ __ ] okay you know
how about this how about this
these poor bastards how about this i
used to love
attacking these people but now it's like
i feel
so badly for them let's let's do
something because
you know we're looking at his b stuff
why don't we look at his a stuff why
don't we look at the monsters in the
morning
monsters in the morning really where
it's where everybody it's like this show
where me and roy's just bring our a game
middle of the day we're swinging hard
and hard yeah monsters in the morning uh
the their show from yesterday let's see
there's
i love making fun of these [ __ ] so
these guys are the biggest show here
see i don't like i feel bad now picking
on carlos
and or megan because they're just shitty
youtubers with a hundred views
but i although you know they made a a
youtube channel for their kid
so that does make me hate them really
yeah i never brought it up because i
don't want these
cyclists to find it but yeah their kid
has one which makes me hate them
that being said these guys are a fair
target of course because these are the
legends they for real they've been these
guys have been in florida
for 20 years doing this show okay 20
years
they're a staple here they they
sponsored that aaf game like you know
they
they they they're always at uh
as a matter of fact i almost went to it
eric fernandez sent me a thing carlos
navarro was hosting
a synthwave thing and i couldn't go
because i had to do something else but i
was going to just go to show up that
would have been
like hey what's up bro yeah but you can
see they're staying as
as [ __ ] royce just said here they are
staples here in orlando and uh
just like those wind socks are stapled
to the microphones
that's your [ __ ] [ __ ] oh i was
like
oh that's the challenge you guys have a
weird bedroom routine
yeah make me some car let's get some
carlos that's because that's a plane
like if you play in a door
or it's a plan and and there's a reason
why you have to plane
the whip i don't even know what that is
so i have no clue oh man uh i think
you've seen it before
like it's like a sander kind of deal
kind of like a standard but it's
basically what it is you'd use it so you
don't get splinters yeah and if you
don't
smooth it out this is amazing radio guys
by the way to compare it to something
uh i i mention this show very uh often
uh come town i love i love listening to
come down
and nick mullen is completely creep
who got into woodworking he could talk
about woodworking for 10 minutes but
it's still funny
right like it's weird how you could take
you could swap somebody out and put
somebody else in and go all right you
talk about sanding wood now
and for some reason he can tell a story
where he just comes off like an ass
this is just yes i got one of the blah
blah what do you call about woodland
you'll see a little royce i woodland one
of those things that
spins the wood and then you hold the eye
like a
you know you can mount like a like some
sort of blade type thing and you can cut
like table legs
and uh grooves into the little wood you
ever see something like that
i eat it i hate it you'll see something
like that right i hate a boy
stuff like that i've seen it i've seen
it russ
we've all seen it russ i want to go work
for one day in terrestrial radio again
just to do that i want to do it just to
snap immediately
so i'm like is she a bigot like is this
the worst bigot in the world
um oh yeah he does
yeah what is it with butthole eyes he
does a lot a lot of people with butthole
eyes they always messed up
they said racism always messed that up
they said
[ __ ] steve buscemi over here
it's like thompson he really does
[ __ ] aviators
people make fun of my eyes but wear some
sunglasses
holy [ __ ] those bags holy [ __ ] the
hispanic no it's more bigotry or another
term
but we are not a race i am caucasian
angel is caucasian gotcha but he is a
hispanic descent so
uh so you know um you know it's nice
is it a tough one carlos well basically
what i was saying is
uh carlos when we built
i love this we're gonna have probably
you know the whites over here or the
blacks over here we're gonna use
hispanics as sort of like a buffer zone
you know like a
like a demilitarized demilitarized zone
uh between the blacks of the whites what
do you think of that carl it's like i
was saying russ you know dude like bro
like bro i was saying like why do they
have wooden doors you know what i mean
what was the point of the wooden doors
dude sometimes you gotta ask yourself
why they built a roller coaster to
i know it's a lot of why you got a
diving team in a swimming pool
yeah you know i want to tell you this
weekend i'll be taking money on the hot
we're going to re-air the soccer matches
and we'll be taking donations here
on monsters in the that's right guys
russ
the monsters of the morning reminding
you to check out greatest story never
told remember to join us universal
studios this weekend we're gonna be
handing out
uh free passes of course foo fighters
gonna be in town this weekend and
uh of course remember he did nothing
wrong we'll be back next week
and it's in the morning coming up next
we have the new one from
johnny rebel why were they talking
johnny rubble
we're talking race right yeah the guy
didn't make no they were they
anyway coming up next we're gonna have
our guest christopher cantwell joining
us here
masters of the morning we're gonna talk
about privacy of the media coming up
next
monsters orlando's number one warning
station
[Laughter]
oh you think they're gonna like when i
clip this and i make monsters
you think they're going to enjoy it
because they trust me all these guys
orlando was really great for a while
till the blacks started moving it you
know originally the blacks and puerto
ricans uh
uh straight out there kissimmee but that
yeah they're really starting to seep
into this place ah like a bunch of
cockroaches
anyway we're going to be coming up next
time i got weekend passes for universal
of our first seven callers
i'll be carlos carlos is always doing
one of these
so listen look not in my neighborhood i
don't
want them in my neighborhood bro carlos
okay dude carlos is rubbing it on his
gums
and coming up next cardo's motivational
quarter i'll be saying the
just russ is just going on and on about
well you know you
you realize too that the uh the english
and americans they bombed the food
trains
uh so the camps couldn't get food you
know
anyway uh some silver chair coming up
playing here just a little bit monsters
in the morning
we have mike enoch coming in today mike
enoch will be in the studio
ah never mind just found out he's we're
gonna be cancelling that
mikey knock is no longer allowed in the
studio
in the morning alt-right radio
all right radio that's not um
you're saying his name can change his
name to russ lincoln rockwell
i like that i love it coming up in just
a little bit of course we'll be giving
away uh passes to disney world this
weekend
coming up my interview with dr david
duke he's going to be coming up here in
the second hour
and don't forget this weekend we'll be
going on it's a small world and booing
all the non-white countries
make sure to boo when you go through
africa folks oh
[ __ ] that was a good bit that's that's
like old school
oh it was good stuff monsters
sorry hmm we'll be at twin peaks this
weekend
that's right we're gonna have our
chicken wing eating contest everyone
come down
of course if you're not a jew or we
don't want to know
either
[Laughter]
i like lesbians oh [ __ ]
that would be another one coming up next
boxers of the board i would be
interviewing
jessie lee peterson coming up here in
the second hour
obviously they're all made of males
shmation talking over his dentures
close your eyes you swear to the real
people
[Laughter]
sorry this is such a stupid day
sorry sorry guys
monsters west virginia racist lady in
the restaurant well i think
because she's i mean she's just yelling
at this guy and she's like go back to
your own country right right she's just
gross
i agreed with her i was like i second
that go back to your own god damn
third world [ __ ] that's what russ
told her let's push that african migrant
on the ground and stole her purse
let's take all his stuff out of context
now
i told that [ __ ] go back to your own
country get obama phone over there if
you want
call it a vincente fox phone i don't
care puts on a maga hat
coming up next we're going to be
discussing the correlation between race
and iq
justin lee peterson coming up next
monsters in the morning
you know i'm happy they found out that
jesse smelled the thing was a hate crime
but i'm upset that they didn't beat up
another n-word
sorry monsters in the morning she's not
like at a taco bell either like some
version of like an american
that's not a chipotle a taco bell this
is like a like your standard mexican
amigos style restaurant
uh for fm radio in the morning right
like not even not even doing the bit
i mean i know we're doing the bit but
even on iran like right now days when
they go like
these up come no i've seen russ cross
people yeah you got to watch it now all
right be careful
not the 90s anymore hondurans or
hondurans
what do you expect for the i mean so so
we speak spanish so what
uh but she's she's here in america you
need to speak america
they're in west virginia man there are
like 11 hispanic people in west virginia
that's actually you know what you're
wrong there's a lot of hispanic people
you're completely wrong carlos and by
the way wait let me see let me guess
because
local boarding radio shows can get away
with this like [ __ ] and cuddling
other west virginians a bunch of
hillbillies
because nobody's gonna check and by the
way politically just to obviously these
guys are all bunch of liberals
they wanted what's-his-face for governor
like uh carlos was talking about him
because listen to this oh the black guy
that wanted to create
income tax he wanted to take a state
that has no income taxes and create one
and create one
and then gilliam he would carlos was
saying he wanted gilliam because gilliam
was going to bring more holly
more tv shows to florida because he's a
big actor of course
and uh it was just so cringe so that's
what they are politically they're a
bunch of [ __ ]
uh soy boy beta cucks
being done in a mexican restaurant no
and and that's all it is it's just a
stupid old bigot that's never been
around hispanic people
everybody outside of my big beautiful
blue city
hey guess what bigot i'm hispanic and
you're a [ __ ] sp
with your goddamn gold necklace and
you're [ __ ] still worried
you're cuban link necklace and your gold
chains
pretending like you're some [ __ ] sort
of sort of
tony montana [ __ ] shut up shut
up you married the whitest woman in
america
at it and watching tv and listening to
our president rail how we have a
national emergency at the border
and this is what you get you get people
that are it's trump's fault did you hear
this [ __ ]
did you hear this mother first off we're
just gonna make fun of you
but now now you [ __ ] you're a
carlos national emergency at the border
and this is what you get you get people
that are
that are so upset at their own life that
they have to take it out on a mexican
waiter now there is someone that does
get involved if you look at the end
there is
shut the [ __ ] up carlos you're blaming
trump
you're carlos you're a loser you're a
you're not you're not a has been
you're in never was okay you [ __ ] you
feel good having to go to a [ __ ]
nightclub in your [ __ ] almost
40s and stand there instead of being
home with your wife and kids because
those local radio station doesn't give
you enough money you [ __ ]
loser oh do you feel happy having to
take down the monsters in the morning
sign behind you
because phillips file the actual show
that makes money
for real 104.1 his [ __ ] logo was put
there permanently
that's why that's why monsters in the
morning was syndicated and quickly uns
unsyndicated immediately because you're
a bunch of [ __ ] hack losers
but you're right it's trump's fault your
[ __ ] embarrassment carlos
you're a [ __ ] embarrassment is that a
man or a woman that gets involved
who's like telling her to hush up but
it's crazy that they're just sitting
there uh
filming it uh what would you ryan what
would you do
if you ryan holmes is the producer they
they had a thing every year monsters in
the morning where they would have a
comedy festival
and whoever won the comedy festival will
be their third mic for the year
they didn't have one this year and they
kept this ryan guy but it's also because
i think this ryan guy set them up on
youtube because they're a bunch of
boomers
yeah they're idiots brothers by the way
ryan looks just like the sloth
from uh ice age i still want to know
where the who gets the money
i'm very curious about that what do you
mean oh the youtube that's what i'm
thinking
i got to imagine russ is a money guy i
guarantee russ is not going to let
[ __ ] this guy keep the money you know
and this woman's yelling at this guy i
mean you know what no that's not true
short of like hey we can't pay you much
but i tell you what kid
why don't you keep the youtube super
chats that'll be your pay
you know they probably have some sort of
deal worked out like that
i and all this would you uh would you
say something uh as soon as i see this
happening
guys i want to make an announcement yes
we do have control now uh over
uh cux for bernie.com that's hours
well it's not hours it will be but it
will it's a it's an ally
and ally obtained uh post a flag over
there for us
and they will forward it to oh [ __ ] cux
for bernie
f.o.r was taken already so you got the
number four yeah that's fine i like that
that's that's even better that's even
better
this is my favorite thing in the world i
pull out my phone immediately how do
they all
sound the same how do all local fm
people sound the same that vocal fry
is the [ __ ] worst
you're a loser carlos you're a [ __ ]
loser
and your producer's a loser and russ
russ
by the way this isn't me doxing anybody
it was all over the news here
his wife samantha boomer that's her real
name
divorced him and accused russ
she accused russ of choking her and
hitting her
right she sent me this in the news uh
now it was settled out of court i do
know this
by reported by uh the local news here
welsh 13 i think wesh 13 right he said
that he had to pay 8 000
a month to her in alimony
uh and i don't know if that had to do
with her not pressing charges or
anything
that is how much money russ is has to
pay every month i did really get that he
got to keep his boat can i speculate
sure we could always speculate i'm just
speculating here
but i think that that wasn't the
beginning of the end of the
the rust dossier oh no i don't think so
i think that was just
what what spilled out into a public
event that the cops got involved in
yeah i think that there were stories
i think there was eight thousand dollars
a month worth worth of stories
i think and probably an nda was signed i
think you're right after the 8 000 a
month
8 000 a month dude hey that's a big
settlement
you don't get that it's especially like
the rust money but he ain't making
crazy money like that that is somebody's
got 8 000
worth of stories